time grows short my friends
even now belial's influence is spreading
through chaldea
but how will we find him we won't have
to
magda and her coven i'm not going
anywhere until decker deserves that
honor i have called for a caravan to
guide us to the east
my friend shall we depart to caldium
[Music]
it was all just stories
my uncle saw what he wanted to see
deckard sacrificed much to protect this
world
but his work is not over how would you
know about sacrifice
[Music]
the ancient law of the high heaven
strictly forbids us from interfering
with the mortal world
yet you have done so brazenly all i am
guilty of imperius
is bringing justice while you hide
cowering behind your throne silence
you will now answer for your
transgressions
um
you cannot judge me
i am justice itself we were meant
for more than this to protect
the innocent but if our precious laws
bind you all to inaction
then i will no longer stand as your
brother
you chose to be
one of us
is
thus i fell willingly
because humanity is the only hope
for this world i never believed
all your crazy tales the work
you never finished
[Music]
i will finish it uncle i will carry on
for you
[Music]
now that tristram is safe
i travel to caldean
the great city of the east
it has fallen before one of the last
lords of hell
been dialed i mean to set
the city free
you